there is breaking news from the Muller
investigation around exactly sure what
some of it means but it is coming at us
right now former FBI director Jim Comey
testified by the way on Capitol Hill
today he dropped his initial plans to
amend a legal challenge to the subpoena
he received from Republicans on the
community what did we learn from Comey
on the hill tom Fitton was watching
carefully he is president Judicial Watch
here tell us about that and to assess
the more memos we were just talking
about but first two Comey Tom thanks for
coming on what do we learn we learned
that comedy isn't worried about being
prosecuted for any misconduct because he
didn't take the fifth and we also
learned the FBI and Justice Department
are still hampering the investigation by
ordering and not the answer many key
questions according the Republicans
who've complained about the way it
proceeded we didn't call me am i
overstating this and I want to be fair
but it seemed to me like Comey committed
perjury last time he testified because
he said that he had never participated
in a leaking while FBI director and then
Andy McCabe who would know later said
that he had did anyone ask him about
that well I don't know but I guess it
depends on what the meaning of leak is I
guess he took those FBI memos FBI files
of Donald Trump and leaked them with the
specific purpose of getting a special
counsel appointed you know he ought to
be under criminal investigation for
taking those records and leaking them
and he's also under investigation about
potentially taking classified
information and you know if you're under
criminal investigation at the federal
level and someone asks you questions
about it in an official circumstance
like this you often take the fifth are
you starting to mean meanwhile but he
did it destroys a couple s was in prison
until a minute ago are you getting this
is the impression that the the truly
powerful really don't face legal
consequences it's always the little guy
it's always drum corps see some 70 to go
writer for news max who gets threatened
with prison but Jim Comey the FBI
director gets do it every wants that
kind of seems like the looks well it's
not necessarily powerful but it's a
partisan process because president
Trump's powerful but he's being attacked
and abused but if you're connected to
the Democratic establishment if there's
a partisan nature here which is the get
Trump you're protected and mr. Comey is
Muller's witness he appointed Muller
he's friends with me I mean he worked
Muller he's friends with Muller and now
we're seeing what happens if you're one
of friends of a friend of Muller you get
protected by this Justice Department and
this FBI and if you're not a friend of
Muller you'll be used and abused in the
case of Cohen who was used to go after
Trump in a dishonest ways in my view by
this special counsel and he's being
abused and thrown under the bus oh yeah
we use his testimony we were able to
insert the word Russia 50 million times
as a result of these plea deals that
really didn't have anything to do with
Russia collusion but we're gonna ask the
court to allow him to go to jail for at
least three and a half making a lot of
us very cynical and I wish it weren't
because I love this country there was a
ruling today
pertaining to judicial watch and
Hillary's emails what happened well
actually was yesterday was a big ruling
by Judge Royce Lamberth who opened up
discovery into the Clinton email issue
he's angry about what the Justice
Department and the FBI did he he fears
that he was hoodwinked or they tried the
hoodwinked Judicial Watch in the court
and keeping these emails away from us
he's concerned that Hillary Clinton
created this email system to avoid FOIA
and he really went after this Justice
Department for coming into court and
engaging in what he called chicanery to
try to make excuses for and explain away
the misconduct that saw these emails
hidden and the email system used to
avoid court scrutiny congressional
scrutiny and questions from the American
people in fact he asked was Benghazi one
of the reasons they didn't want us to
know about these emails so this
discovery is significant at least and
you know Congress is out to lunch on
this and Justice Department is on the
other side but the court wants more
answers whatever happens the Republican
Congress we got to do a series on that
maybe in January Tom's great you want to
say yeah thank you